[Música]
escala en paris brown ministro alain
paris un programa de radio francia
internacional y colaborativo
confianza 24 un español adicionalmente
atractivo contra Francia pasará de una
economía mundial sube es falso elvino
[ __ ] es el nuestro de la lola
elvino biolay y el dúo burdeos
su favorito es lo que atrae empezó
para revender desde los orígenes a
consumidores de minos tiené con
de ellos por la desaparición de plántulas
cuota anual internacional
burdeos una revisión de la máscara de los pinos
en seis años de educación
vino des chablis en mi bolsa tiene buena
benhida a antonio rodriguez autor de
libros de viticultores si es ecológico para
[ __ ] para saber y amar nivel
quedarse escala en paris y eso es suficiente
corriente de ninguno francia permaneció libre
al público adolescente por la transición de
buscando midi y clark de masami vines
y bailando orgánicamente por sus playas que apuntan
al bise al historial un productor si
me intereso el famoso obino des
ganancia inesperada que exhibe el manzano nimani en
Isabelle Caro finalmente se acercó
de forma biológica para quien tenemos
han enseñado como mirada borracha
es una novedad llega en el tiempo donde
estaba sosteniendo la valla y está en absoluto
obra de los productores divinos y tiene
partió el domingo en el ats denis pommier él
ya isabelle quien es suficiente o no como
esta muerte no se concretó un poco servida
obino orgánico local no orgánico es un
naturaleza máxima respetable a propósito
y techo desde su noveno lugar hasta las palabras vienen
porque si tienen un poco mejor pero
chardonnay de todo el mundo con cuervos o
como acacia 2010 tuvo que mantener
2010 dónde estabas nosotros cuando
tenía una isla 2010 en 6.6 o el candidato
El lugar de lo que ella imaginaba lo tiene todo
prueba este auto una cuenta real
Notario
ella se lo llevo lucenzo cuenta todo el
prueba o rompe todo y su historia
de Borgoña a Chablis
el tiempo es una historia
universal y sus chicos largos
y book antonio pero sabes que me gusta
rosas y su esposa también en la región
las doce en punto que sin duda tienen americano
la ayudan en francia y en borgoña
como también para publicitar nuestros productos
ambient sinautes concreta quiénes son
para perros por sospecha de 70 en
bueno y ahi va dicho en ese momento
fontainois con nosotros se proponen y
Pinot Noir
donde late el pinot noir el aele chardonnay
younes al haouz y la oportunidad como
una familia que tenía su paciente
como base para cassay y saccani para aquellos
Chablis y nuestro productor de polos
supongo que es mi hija
no sabe pasarnos pero gran estrella
ganador del productor adolescente y todo
ser un actor
kohno cm2 como en el trabajo que antes y
mucho de la dificultad de lo que era
niang apio y catania amiens
rinoceronte yuan tamines glauco y
a lo que su aspecto positivo de este
aventura y esta ella murio
bousquet productores divino no la crisis
st es gratis que ahora el
presenta como denis premier quien es
violador obino orgánico más destacado y
que ocupa un contador obedecer el
alas sql 2000 de los seis años después de su
deuda pareja atrevida gasquet tour liel la
sátira que asigna chad
hay que va en los tics y ella lo tiene
buen intento de nico c es especialmente el
temporada siempre que seas serio es
que 2010 y 2010 innovan tenemos a
productor
un podio en el escenario de la cabaña orgánica en el
casas naturaleza cómo hacer un pedido
ni primera pintura lcm y a lucia y c
es decir que me interesa bien digna
surge en isabelle inicia caunes est
adecuado a la población de la
mayoría el otro par burdeos a quien
son más que poner el pedal suave
nla nyomi mauritian todos nuestros
las batallas imperiales se comportaron
los otros productores constructores qué
me conocen y en realidad han sido
de los medios de los años 1000
que no decidiría que papá se estaba convirtiendo
acer producción ecológica y como
el dijo que la cita un vendado y
la lente usó otro trazo de
la naturaleza de su parte avanzada el zafiro y
mafioso y naturalizado y por lo tanto como el
propietario denis sus tiempos y el
camino del asvel se ha naturalizado de la
poder
si es necesario y es bastante pesado
leclerc argana ipv6 - jung murio
marta que tenemos mas de 600 y respeto
canal maquinas y relojeria stoxx 600
de la costa y en 2010 y 6 6 pasa y
sattam intelectual misterioso de la col que
fue totalmente cio llamado stemi
oficiales también nuestras instrucciones dominan el
la naturaleza trata de repetir este mercato
en el trabajo
productores de menta y vino
Suiza para este año se dirige a que
mantenga sus cuentos el intestino y
no te pongas el asistente binoche y
natural no tenemos que damasco pero
atención al éster libre precisamente
la miniatura del argumento de venta la esquina tal es
cual es el signo setenta cavame
sus productores y viticultores eliminando
su rubia en los lagos de las Landas clases de
más como alces inadaptados en el
tasa de opiniones serie de culto años que
vienen de ser animales lamentos
tiendas de mascotas, etc.
simplemente no es parte de nuestros sayos
intacto y un pedazo de historia en pedazos
y permite que el progreso material permanezca
del Chablis arranca una berenjena y
para frecuentar y entrar es de
Sagno Waters no sintió ninguna duda
esta condesa de grecia como voigt
reconocer que los disponibles
líneas enemigas noticias eventos mpman es
espectacular que en la ciudad de el
mundo por quien esta vez somos alcanzados
límites te hizo saber y
tenía siete funcionarios en 2010 seis
programas que deberíamos esperar que
pero nuestras empresas y samassa finalistas
se pregunta ahora si son ellos y
para las fotos es la nacion menor
sistema de frecuencia mas estudiantes en movimiento
dos departamentos yayi y en cadetes ni ne
sabe oponerse si no es
dudo que sea como mr main gonon
herramienta we electric cables oscars
el ambiente está sobrerrepresentado allí en
la espalda nosotros en odos la temperatura
hospitalidad limitada a nueva delhi ella
daría lugar a su situación de crisis de la
el disco era y el pez asi
el deseo de una experiencia es
interesante y enel 2010 si sube y
ella
denis number ado es el mejor bino de
el trabajo de los meses bravo el mejor
chardonnay por muchas causas
compiten como base y 13000 solo iran
chardonnay del mundo de thomas hardy c
es un servicio operado en boca
pila de suerte y 1.300 ha de
delvin vines cuanto más sufren
explotado en sierre y los elixires y
racionalmente orgánica y sobre todo de la
historia humana des graduates deciden me
cuando lo ayudo en la recepcion es genial
hay coincidencias con esa novia
aplaudió dominó y el cóndor que no
no son medidas de 15,7 para estar de pie
decide evitar una subida
aumento orgánico y son apoyados
solo causo bien lo que es a blanco a
todo lo que es francés falso de lo contrario
freak y catherine es un
Fantasear la producción y solo uno tiene
contado ya se apresuró dentro de la
dominio que es myspace para regarnos
están bajo tensión y son viejos
cordero 2010 afp roanne y 2002
otros apuestan por su césped un
situación que ahora llama
otra audiencia en snb ty dennis answer
en su invitación a la gente fueron
presente en sousse binos es vital para
el vendedor estonio qué es
que les prohibe precisamente
buques de producción de petróleo
altibajos biológicos del año
seleccion estados unidos 2010
la gente es la crisis de lehman
hermanos ante situaciones de crisis
recaudado financiero para todos
y que intentaban tan bien desarrollados
a nuestros agricultores la economía la crisis
económico es el objetivo principal pm el
productor de los 2000 otros vinilos de choque
lehman malo hay estas tenencias y
lo que es motivar paso a paso y
bim orgánico y youndé mercado adivinar
organico y el
la prueba es que este crimen enseña
cuenta gratis también lo que es y
los consumidores adivinan orgánico en el líbano
y Washington extrae toneladas de oro
hakim pavimentó este momento y eso es lo que yo
me digo a mí mismo que se bloqueará para cantar un
votado a favor de nacka nuestros productores orgánicos
con respeto a la naturaleza y es como
bebiendo agua destinada nadie sabía quién
fue para un productor a qué sabe
no va a ser menos malo cuenta la costa
está en esteroides y una apuesta
encuentro para captarlos de forma natural y
saludable no posibilidad había cruzado
para ir a la luna hay perdida esta
batalla entre stalin de tempo a la cabeza
cac con moscú no hubiera pasado
resistir mucho tiempo bien
situación a la que se refiere
mencionó que 2010 innovar y no en el
cuerda de crisis en crisis
crisis financiera
2010 solo y senior donald trump
demagogo populista se decidió un
va del 25 en porto al 5 puertas en sion
compañías de vida es 54 y 91
el productor de eminent france 3 que
otras partes del mundo si safina es
se convirtió en el primer concepto que quedó
el programa anterior estado soninké
capriccio a jean e yvonne en
sólo los productores intérpretes o ejecutantes de
conciencia dijo nick leddy generación
en generación para la cual
combinó 1 din orgánico al final con el
vid y él cerca de la arena es
adquirió la aproximación
[Música]
[Aplausos]